all right let's check in on the Herschel
Walker campaign Herschel Walker is the
Republican Senate candidate in Georgia
Herschel Walker knows very little about
anything he had a debate uh last week
during which he flashed a fake badge he
claims to be a police officer he claims
to have trained with the FBI he has been
credibly accused of paying for an
ex-girlfriend's abortion and urging her
to have a second abortion despite
claiming to be vehemently pro-life
against abortion abortion is murder no
exceptions whatsoever except he has paid
for a woman's abortion We are continuing
to follow the breakdown of any semblance
of truth and reality from Herschel
Walker so let's go through piece by
piece first and foremost he was
interviewed Herschel Walker was
interviewed by NBC News
and in this NBC news interview he
continues to claim no I never paid for
anyone's abortion and the explanation
that he gives in this clip suggests
either he doesn't know how many or which
children he has okay that's possible or
you have to believe in time travel for
this explanation to make sense so let me
set it up for you Herschel Walker's new
denial is okay fine I do know the woman
who says I paid for her to get an
abortion after urging her to get an
abortion I did send her a 700 check but
I sent her the 700 check for the child
we have together the only problem
is the check was sent years before that
child was born
so is it a case of time travel did
Herschel Walker travel back in time to
give her the money for a kid that would
be born years later I don't know take a
listen this is still alive because she's
the mother of my child so you're going
to see my chick of somebody giving a
check so that I'm saying it's a lot do
you know what the seven hundred dollars
I have no idea what that can be for is
that your signature
it could be it doesn't matter whether
it's my signature or not yes that's my
check yep okay so yes it's my my
signature yes I sent 700 to this woman
yes I do know the woman despite
previously playing dumb about it until
you no longer could because she's the
mother of one of your children the money
was because we have a child together but
that child did not exist at the time
that he sat the 700 check now in
Herschel Walker's defense if I
understand the timeline he did have a
different kid with a different woman
that very same year it's possible that
he's confused about which woman he sent
the 700 to I don't know the other
possibility is that Walker is confusing
children that he has I just don't know
and it is quite stunning how many media
Outlets continue to accept these bogus
explanations without doing the just
fundamental math it's it's not even
really math it's just understanding time
and that time moves forward as far as we
understand it right now
and that the timing completely debunks
these completely bogus stories and
unfortunately
almost everybody is kind of treating him
with kid gloves on this even during the
debate last week with Raphael Warnock as
I told you one of the worst moderated
debates I've ever seen the moderators
not pressing at all just oh the story is
untrue all right well he says it's
untrue well but hold on a second
is the woman in question the mother of
one of your children well yeah so you do
know the woman yes and you were dating
her at the time that she claims you paid
for her abortion well yeah I guess I was
and is it possible that she became
pregnant due to someone else's doing
well no they could easily break this
down and get to the bottom of it very
very quickly but they can continue to
teach uh treat him with kid gloves and
it is abundantly clear at this point
that he is lying I've seen several
people in my life try to quit smoking or
vaping and quitting has so many benefits
but it does require a strategy and our
sponsor fume is a one-of-a-kind inhaler
that can help you quit smoking as a
replacement for the hand-to-mouth habit
of smoking there is no smoke there is no
vapor and there's no nicotine fume is
just a small inhaler handcrafted from
wood it uses cores infused with fresh
aromatic plant oils for you to taste and
enjoy instead of a nasty cigarette or a
vape you can use fume while flying which
is a big plus because there's no smoke
no Vapor no nicotine fume has flavors
like peppermint and Conquer with a
powerful minty sensation to simulate the
menthol cigarettes they have other
flavors like cozy chai I love chai
myself and lemon berry Bliss for a
sweeter experience fume has helped
thousands of people quit people who have
tried everything else read the reviews
we talked to the fume team they're very
proud of the lives that they've impacted
throw out the cigarettes get rid of the
Vapes head over to
breathefume.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman to get 10
off your entire order the link is down
below